when you tapped into norm's humor
he really
there's absolutely i don't know any i
try to compare him you can't compare him
to anyone and that's what made him
so funny and amazing i mean he had his
dark moments and he had all that stuff
but
he always had an underlying stinging
view
that only he could put out there the way
he can put it out knowing and no one
could ever touch him i remember just
me him and daryl hammond
and just
and you couldn't tell if he was trying
to be funny he was just funny we went to
a steak and shake after a show
he's like yeah yeah and he's stabbing
him
second you guys hungry yeah you get a
very sticky chick right and so
we go in there and um
guys like yeah we're we're at it we're
out of shape he goes what
leaving your had a shake
and he he walks because this is
this is steak
and then a shake right i mean that's
that's the name of it it's not like
steak and we don't have shape
steak
and then he goes he goes outside in the
parking lot but you can hear matt psycho
there's dank side and a shake guy
stay
and shake
baby
do you have milk
[Laughter]
do you have ice cream because yeah
[Laughter]
the shaker ain't working the shaking
work of jesus it's shaking
god damn man
me and me and daryl
you know it's two in the morning which
is
just so damn funny on that same trip he
got kicked out of the state of iowa it
was such a funny entire state of high
hope jesus christ yes well we're playing
the university of iowa and he
and they said listen no cursing
um
don't touch on uh homosexuality don't
touch on religion
and you know there's a lot of kids out
there students brought their families
okay yeah we're gonna sign it up i get
it
dow goes up just 20 clean funny
i go up do 20 and
i think i do great
norm goes up
like he's like
like he just woke up he goes
[Music]
where the [ __ ] we at
[ __ ]
and then he goes right out of the gate
right out of the gate
let me ask them
if you're gay because you have no
problem if you are i mean if you're gay
that's your choice you know but if
you're gay
[Music]
would you rather be the ass guy
or the dick guy because
i mean think about it you're the ass guy
you're like oh my gosh
jessica's around my testicles and
they're just kind of touching and kind
of hurts and he's touching my spleen and
like oh my god this is painful but if
you're the dick guy
and people are just grabbing their
families and heading up the aisles
the more he got it i mean me and barrel
is just going oh i can't believe what
i'm witnessing and the next day they
were like norm mcdonald's been kicked
out of state by the governor never to
return
um and he was on lettering the next day
talking about it was the funniest thing
i ever see in my life knowing that i
watched that whole thing go down